the fifth wave to the fifth wave is an
alien invasion movie that's based off of
a young adult adaptation novel because
we're in the fifth wave of that [ __ ] now
we have Chloe grace Moretz and then the
aliens come and there are four waves
leading up to the fifth way first wave
is an EMP that takes out all the
electronics around the earth second wave
or tsunamis and earthquakes third wave
is like the bird flu kills people in the
fourth wave is pretty much invasion of
the body snatchers with crappy romance
mixed into it in the fifth wave is total
annihilation
alright so among that we have Chloe
grace Moretz trying to get to her
brother because her brother is in this
military facility where they're training
the kids to fight the alien which is
funny about this movie because if I
explained this movie to someone in a
positive light there's enough potential
to make it sound good but potential
reality folks it's all about execution
this movie had none of that [ __ ] simple
fixes could have fixed a lot of things
in this movie I mean you can pick it
right out you're like if they had done
that it would have been better example
this is one example among many scenarios
that could have used to fix that you
will see plain as day if you watch this
movie and if you watch it it means you
don't listen to me ever so look this is
scene where this one recruit in the
military is training with this other
tough girl in the military so they're
gonna spar and dialogue among sparring
is a pretty easy way to bond characters
together it happens all the time in
movies I just do a couple hits and then
it's over and I was like granted it
would have been a cliche ass thing but
at least it would have been a thing at
this point you're not even trying just
like character let's get back to Chloe
grace Moretz and her shitty ass romance
oh my god there's just one dude in this
movie hooks up with Chloe grace Moretz
and then they start having this romance
I'm telling you guys this guy starts
laying it on thick at one point in this
movie guys I've seen a lot of [ __ ] I
have seen some [ __ ] this is right up
there with all of it man this is some of
the worst romance I have ever heard in a
movie if this dude was just vaporised
out of this movie the movie it'd almost
be bearable moment he started laying
that on I was like you're killing it
your kids stop it stop you are killing
this now that there was much air to
begin with but at least I could be
entertained with the first waves of
attacks that the aliens were doing that
was cool even the first scene in this
movie was really cool so it really sets
you up to what you think could be a
pretty enjoyable experience
now then I'm going to get the teenage
girls coming back what is AB shots and
shitty dialogue I mean the AB shots did
show the ABS dude was a beefcake I'll
say but holy crap just don't have them
thar he's like shut your mouth shut your
mouth and the pacing in this movie but
for how long do you think you can see
someone walk from point A to point B
just traveling with shitty dialogue
mixed in there not long not for two
hours I can tell you that and once you
realize this movie is just sloppy ice
writing then any twists and turns that
want to take in this movie you see
coming a mile away
you're like yeah I almost think that's
going to happen but that's too easy but
now I know they take the easy route so
yep no more surprises guys the fifth
wave was disappointing and I say
disappointing because it didn't look
like it was gonna be shitty it has a
solid premise it has great potential
it even has scenes where you're like
it's good to save the note and that
romance just piledrive this movie into
yesteryear and all of this stacks
together making you walk out of the
movie going I'm never going to see that
again in fact I'm not gonna remember it
in t-minus one day ya already forgot or
so your favorite alien invasion movie
what is it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you wanna
see more click right here to see more